[音楽]
みなさんこんにちは
はじめましてクリスタルパっ子チャンミンしていると申します
私はこの水晶玉を使ったパフォーマンスで様々なイベントやパーティーで小させて
いただいております
この水晶玉を使ったパフォーマンスをいろんなところで演じているとこんなことを言わ
れます
すごいねぇとか
どうやって置いてるのとか
あと普通じゃできないわとか
いや発送普通じゃないねぇ
こんな言い方をされます
日本のお客様とか友人から
今日はですね
この手でエクソンテーマ
アンランプルスということでアンランは今あなたが知っていることを一度常識を
解き放って学びなおす
そしてプルスは今日私がお話ししたことを中から何かでご自身のアクションを起こして
いただく
そんなメッセージが込められています
今日のテックスで僕は普通という言葉さっき僕が話したように普通という言葉について
ちょっと話しをしようと思います
皆さん
っていう言葉日常でよく使うと思います
2はこうするよ
いやーちょっと普通じゃないよねと
屋富祖れちょっと普通すぎないところ
普通ってなんですか
周りに合わせるのが普通ですか
目立たないのが普通ですか
それとも毎日健康で過ごすのが普通でしょうか
日本で普通の生活っていうと普通の人生というと小学校中学校高校って上がって大学に
行って
大学から就職活動して就職活動してそっからまあ定年まで働いて老後を迎える
これが普通の人生ってよく日本では言われていますよね
でも
それがもし普通なのだとしたら
この人生は
小学校4年生のところから普通じゃなかったんです
僕はですね小学校4年生の時
周りに合わせるのがすごく苦手な子供だったんです
自分では変わったことをしようと亀田とって勇気はないんです
でも周りと同じことがなかなかできなかったんです
先生が言った通りにみんなができるように僕はできなかったんです
周りの子たちがやっていることとか遊んでいることに僕は一緒に付いていくのが
難しかったんです
だんだん学校が苦しくなってきましたん
人と何かを一緒に行ったり学校に行くのが辛くなってきて最終的にはお前は変わってる
お前は変だっていじめられたんです
その結果僕はですストレスで
脳と神経を完全にダウンさせてしまいまして
重度の強迫性障害という病気デー
閉鎖病棟に緊急入院しました
偏差病棟って皆さんご想像されるとかすごく暗くて閉ざされた場所というイメージが
あると思うんですけれども
僕のいた病棟っていうのは天井に監視カメラがあって
窓にはこうやって策がついていて出られなくなっていて
自分の部屋にはベッドと簡単なイスと机があって
自分の部屋を出ると
赤いラインがこうやって弾いてあってここから先は言ってはいけませんって自分の行動
の範囲が決められているそんな場所でした
そこに入院していた子供達は
本当に過酷な状況の子供たちばかりです
人と話すことができなくなってしまった洸
毎日のように自殺衝動に駆られてしまう
毎日のように不安が頭から消えなくて気絶するほど頭痛に苛まれる高本当に沢山の子供
達がいましたその中に僕は一人入っています
岡やがて単位制
普通の学校に戻りました
でもそこは
自分が最初から見ていた日常の狭間にすごく不気味に見えたんです
皆が同じことができているながちゃんと先生の言うことに従ってちゃんとできている
それがすごく僕にとって不気味でした
それから高校2年生もで約7年間僕は治療を続けていましたその7年間ずっと考え続け
ました
ルってなんだ
2じゃないってなんだ
みんなが普通なのか
自分は普通じゃないの
ずっとこうやって考えたんです長年間ずっと
7年間高校2年生になるまですと考えていたんですけど
答えが出なかったんですよ
普通というものを正体がつかめなかったんです
高校2年生の時に
僕ある決断をしました昔から自然だったり動物だったりそういったものが大好きだった
僕は憧れてた国があったんです
ニュージーランドという国なんですけれども
大自然とすごいたくさん動物とすごい独自の静大外径があるすごい面白い国なんです
そこに行ってみたいと思って
17歳の時に自分の通っていた高校を辞めて一人ニュージーランドへ渡りました
そう時僕体重38キロしかなかったらず薬の副作用とかデー
の向こうについてどんな生活なのかな
苦しいから楽しいかなって不安を期待を心に抱きながら向こうに行ったんですけど
そこで待ち構えていたのは衝撃の光景でしょ
バスにのレバー
おじさんが裸足に上等でピッとやって乗ってくるんです
スーパーに行こうとしたら
60歳ぐらいのおじちゃんがスケートボードにエンジンをつけてすごい速さでブーンだ
言ってくださいよ
ドヤ顔で
すごいだろうみたいな会うたびに速くなっていくですねその出力が強くなっていくんん
である時はねあのなんか悩んでる人が入ってどうしたんですかって言ったらイヤウまで
行くか自転車でかずっと悩んでのどっちでもいいわみたいな
どうでもいいわけだよそんな国なんですよ
でもその人たちが変わってるとかおかしいとかそういうことはなくて
みんなそれぞれそんな感じ自由にやっててお互いにそうやって自由なことを認めてて
世界中から移民が来て集まってすごい豊かななんかいろいろな文化が混ざっちゃったり
国なんです
なんでみんなそれぞれ好き勝手やっててそれで上手く
入ってるってそんな国なんです
そこに入ってね僕わかったんですよ
うっていうのは
これ自分の中にあるんだジンスとかそういうのじゃない文化でもない考え方でもやって
いることでも性別でも病気のあるなしでもなくて自分自身のがやっていることこそ全部
普通なんだっ
普通っていうのは誰かが決めるをんじゃなくて自分の中に初めからあるものなんだって
こうやって思ったんです
他そんなこんなで3年間ニュージーランド過ごしました
3年経って二十歳になりますハタチになって北日本に帰ってきたんですね
日本に帰ってきてからまあ体は元気になり
最初に考えたのはこの後どうしようという
仕事とか外資系の会社とか入った方がいいのかなとか英語とか喋れたんだ
いろいろ悩んだんですけどとりあえず大学に入ることにしました
それがこの青山学院大は家だったんです
4年間あれば何かしら自分の行く先は見つかるだろうてその淡い期待を抱きながら結構
適当な理由で僕は大学に入りました
それからこの水晶玉に電話までの期間わずか1カ月でした
入学生から1か月後に出会ってしまったんですこれにキョンな理由で
すごくこれ最初パフォーマンスとしてみたいな恐怖のすごくおもしろくてなんだこれは
ってなってやってみたいと思っちゃったんですね
でも日本にはこれに関しての教材だったり dvd だったり先生だったら教室だっ
たりそういうものが一切なくて
独学で始めたんです見よう見まねで youtube とか見ながら
て最初趣味でやってたんですよ大学に通いながら趣味でこれを練習しててだんだん
だんだんうまくなってきてだんだん団の人に見せたいと思ってきて結構
近所の子供とか島立とかに店でビックリさせるって行ってたんです
そのと完全に趣味でやってましたん
ある時よく行ってたカフェの店長さんから今度家でパーティーがあるからそこでこれ
やってくれないかなとやいいですよって言ったら
もちろんお金を支払いするんでてはたんです
びっくりしましたさ
いいんですかって思っ
初めて
仕事になったんですこれが
その時のパーティーすごく大成功して
でだんだんだんだん希望大きくなってきましたん
パーティーから始まって地域のお祭りに行って服施設1点で商業施設からのホテルから
いろんなところに行っていろんなところで
水晶玉のパフォーマンスを演じ量になってたんです今でもいろんなとこ行ってます
ようちえんだったりいろんなとこ行ってどんどん希望大きくなってついに
この間イタリアからで中来て
ローマでテレビ出てくれっていうテレビ局金なんか着て
ローマまで行ってきます
これがローマへ連れて行ってくれたんです
好きで始めたものがこんな風にここまで連れてってくれました
僕は大学はですね実はもう既に辞めています
中退するとき周りの大人はいやもったいないよ絶対卒業したほうがよこれいつまで続く
か分からないんだからってずいろんな人言ってくれたんです
いつもある意味で捉えてないんです僕はその人たちにとっては絶対それが普通なんです
よ僕もそう思いますそれぞれの普通があってその普通からアドバイスをしてくれている
んですそれを踏まえた上で僕は
いや自分の中で進む道は多分これだなってもう確信があったんで
そうママ愛は学園であるかと中退したんですね
中退して思ったことなんですけれども大学中退するって言うとすごいとんでもないこと
に感じる人が結構いると思うんですけれども
なんか中退して大きな道を外れるっていう
なんかイメージが強いんですけどいざ外れてみるとその先に道がいっぱいあるんですね
相変わらずこれは面白い場所に連れて行ってくれるし面白い人に出会わせてくれるし
これのお陰で今ここに立っています
あとは自分が好きなこと挑戦したいこともっと他にもあるなって思ってせっかく元気に
なったんだから持って行ってみようって言っていろんなことをやってみました
ライターやってみたりホームページ作るのやってみたり
海外のかわいい雑貨とか輸入して販売するやつやってみたりいろんなことやってみて
全部が好きなこと挑戦したいことやってみたら全部が大切な趣味か誇りが持てる仕事
どちらかになるんです
今は仕事だけじゃありません僕は家庭も持っています
こうやって大きな道を外れてもその先には必ず自分だけの普通自分だけの道っていうの
は必ずそこには存在します
今日このスピーチを聞いてくれているあなたに伝えたいことが一つだけあります
それは年齢は関係ありませんいつからとかもありません
自分が好きなことをやってみたいことがもしあなたがあるならば今日からでいいです
少しでもそれに割く時間を増やしてみてください
どんなことでも大丈夫なんです
何でもいい自分が好きなこと挑戦したいことだったらちょっとずつでもいいんで1日の
中でやる時間を増やしていくとだんだんだんだんそれが育っていくんですそうすると
だんだんだんだん自分の中でもっとそれが大切なものになってきていつのまにかそれを
している自分が普通になってくるんです
そうやって繰り返していると好きなこと挑戦してみたいことってどんどんどんどんやっ
ているとどんどんどんどんそれが自分を形作っていくんです
結構日本は何か頑張ってる人があるとその仕事に何のとかそう金稼げないでしょういて
食っていけないよ
こういうことを意味するんですけどそれちょっと僕はおかしいなと思ってるんです
だって好きなことをしている挑戦したいことに挑戦するそれ自体に意味があるんであっ
てお金っていうのは誰かに価値を届けたその先についてくるものなんです
先に来るのはおかしいんですお金お金目的で始めたわけじゃないんですか
こんな話があります甲木ニュージーランドにた時なんですけれども
こんな手紙が付いたこんな得るでできたちっちゃいハンドメイド作品が書けねえに
ポイってをせて鳴らすこれ落ちているとそのまま写真撮ります
見つけてくれてありがとうございますこれはあなたのですって回転捨て紙に
マジでへと思ったんですね拾ってあ
んだねどういうことって思ったですよ手紙がついて作った人の名前とかも書いてあって
下にこのリンクだったんですねこの青い本してそこフェイスブック見見てみたんです
これで行ってみたらなんか lost and found プロジェクトって書いて
あっていう
なんかハンドメイド作品を作れる人とか趣味で何か作っている人が自分の作ったものに
手紙をつけて
街のどこかに放置しましょうという見つけた人にあげるっていうそういうプロジェクト
でいろんなところにこれに参加して人が設置したらしくて結構街歩いていると時折
見つけるんですよボトルに入ったプレゼントみたいの
声面白いなと思ってどんどんどんどんそれ何か大きくなっていって
これって別にお金払って買ってるわけでも向こうがお金払ってるわけでもなんでもなく
てただお金を返さないでただ楽しい好きだ誰かなんか貰ってくれるから喜ぶかなってあ
見つけたってただ楽しい気持ちだけがそこに残るんですすごいなっても好きなことを
する
何かに挑戦するって本来こういうことじゃないかなって僕は思ったんです
なので自分の好きなこと挑戦したいことに
少しでも時間を割いてみてくださいできるできないとか結果が出る出ないじゃなくて
それに取り組んでいる自分の心っていうのが一番豊かになるんです
もう一つ僕から伝えたいことがあります
それは自分の周りにいる人に感謝をしてくださいということです
僕は今までこうやって好き放題やってきたんですけど本当にたくさんの人に迷惑をかけ
てきます
同時に自分の中ではたくさんの人に価値を届けてきた
今を届けていてこれからも届け続けるというそういう誇りがあります
人って誰かに迷惑をかけられることとかける事っていうのすごく恐れるんですけど迷惑
をかけないで大人れる人成長していける人し寝る人誰もいません
迷惑をかけることをかけられることを恐れずに迷惑をかけてもいいかけられてもいい
その分
誰かに自分が価値を届けることができればそれでいいんですお互いにそうやって
助け合って人は発展してきたんですそれを忘れちゃいけませんだから自分の周りにいる
人に必ず感謝をしなきゃいけないんです
同時に一人で成功するったんでそんなことはできません
どんな人でも必ず誰かの支えがあって成功してるんです自分1人でやってやったぞとか
自分はこんなに偉いんだぞってなった瞬間に
そこで人は僕は終わりだと思います
僕が伝えたいことそれは普通っていうのは自分の中にあるということそして
好きなことをやってみたいことに挑戦するその気持ちが自分自身を形作るということ
そして周りの人に感謝を忘れなければ一緒にもっと面白い世界に届いていけるという
ことそれを伝えたいです
今日の僕のスピーチのタイトルアブノーマライズというタイトルを付けました
これ僕の好きな曲のタイトルでもあるんですけどノーマルっていうのは普通っていう
意味です
ノーマライズっていうのは普通にするって意味です
アブノーマ rize っていうのはその言葉の通り普通じゃない状態にするっていう
んです
もしこのスピーチを聞いているあなたがかつての自分のように
実体のない普通っていうものに恐れて捕らわれて動けなくなっているのならば
たまにはアブノーマないず自分には普通という存在に背を向けて
自由に歩いていくのも面白いと思います
あなたの心の鎖が少しでも溶けたら幸いですご清聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]